if you were here yesterday for Candace's
ordination or if you noticed last Sunday
when Stefan and Imogen and baby xanthi
returned if you pay attention today when
we Commission 20 student deacons you may
see something that people don't identify
with church very much at least here at
least in these last few weeks church is
fun church is an occasion for genuine
joy church is a celebration of life in
its fullness a celebration of birth of
accomplishments of new members of our
community of healing celebration of
diversity of drawing the circle wider
and wider to include more and more
people but don't tell anyone because we
wouldn't want to spoil anyone's
presumption that Christians are
resentful judgmental hypocrites we
wouldn't want anyone to think that we
could have fun here after all religion
is very serious business certainly don't
read them today's Gospel story or if you
must try to use big words and find deep
mystical meanings that will take all the
fun out of it because you wouldn't want
anyone knowing that st. John makes the
first of Jesus's great miraculous signs
creating a hundred gallons of amazing
wine for a big party that had run dry
this is that this is the first miracle
don't tell anybody
because it really doesn't sound very
religious does it we wouldn't want
anyone to know what we're up to after
all this Jesus is a very serious fellow
if you ever watched Jesus movies I think
I've seen them all if you notice in
Jesus movies jesus never blinks he
always has this penetrating x-ray stare
so whether you think he's a Marxist
revolutionary in your mind or a soul
Saving moral crusader or a theological
being whose nature's inspire long winded
debates in Greek no matter which of
these you believe in he is very very
serious but what do you do when you read
a story like this from the Gospel of
John with it's hilariously deadpan
dialogue which is either deeply mystical
in a way I don't understand or perhaps
is an attempt to portray how real
families completely fail to communicate
with each other I think its realism
Jesus well Mary comes to Jesus at the
village wedding and she says they have
no wine and Jesus says to Mary my hour
is not yet come
and mary says to the servants do
whatever he says it's almost like a
movie badly dubbed from a foreign
language and it goes on Jesus to the
servants fill these giant jugs with
water and then give some to the caterer
and the caterer to the groom are you
crazy now you're bringing out the dough
impairing yawn we never even see Jesus
wave his hands over the jugs of water
the miracle itself in the story is only
implied of course there are deeper
meanings to the story wouldn't be John's
Gospel if there weren't mysterious
numbers and repeating symbols but
there's no escaping the fact that Jesus
is all about the party
and it's not just any party and it's
inserted getting drunk because that was
generally unacceptable to choose at that
time it's not just any party that Jesus
is in favor of or that he arrives at
it's a wedding feast the one truly
overflowing celebration of a poor
Israeli peasants life for three or four
days this poor farmer or tradesman and
his bride were no longer nobody's just
one more surf but they are prince and
princess for these days hosting their
entire village for a celebration of life
and new life everyone in the village
game young or old friend or enemy
because these two people and their life
were worth celebrating with extravagance
when Jesus later was struggling to find
words people could understand about what
the world would look like when God's
kingdom comes he said over and over and
over again it's like a wedding feast
everyone comes everyone eats too much
everyone has a great time
but don't tell anybody what will people
think if they knew we worship to God
who's eternal blessed Kingdom is like a
village wedding feast it's not very
churchy at all everyone comes everyone
eats too much everyone has a great time
it sounds like the stereotype of an
Italian family reunion not Church not
exactly what people think Christians
dream of in the midst of this particular
wedding feast in Cana there is a serious
problem as one Lutheran commentator put
it the four saddest words in the entire
scriptures they have no wine
because if you remember your Bible the
prophets have always said that when in
that Kingdom all the nations are
gathered to Zion and worship God there
there would be wonderful unlimited food
and wine for the poor and the hungry of
the earth Jesus is not about to let this
wedding feast this small foretaste of
that Kingdom and an embarrassment and
scarcity this he thinks is a celebration
of life in its fullness and the wine he
knows will not run out so very quietly
off to the side we don't even know how
he somehow creates wine so the
celebration can go on but it means even
more Brian staff Reagan writes that at a
Middle Eastern wedding of the time the
friends of the two families would get
together and they would pledge their
money so that this big party that the
families couldn't afford could happen so
if as in this story you run out of wine
it's a sign that you've run out of
friends Jesus would not let that happen
by there when you run out of wine what a
friend we have in
Jesus first miracle is to quietly ensure
that this celebration of life can go on
because in Jesus's kingdom there will be
no wedding feast the run out so often I
think today and it's a stereotype but
Christians are seen in the world out
there as angry cramped tight people
worried that someone somewhere is having
a good time or that someone who only got
a c-minus in holiness might be let into
heaven Christians we are told are people
fixated on rules and membership
standards Christians or people who enjoy
disapproving of everyone else so don't
tell them this story from the Gospel of
John don't tell them the song that we
heard today psalm 36 that we sang don't
tell them about this God whose
unwavering love extends beyond human
imagination whose faithfulness is deeper
than the universe this God who loves
everything that is right and fair this
God amazingly if you noticed that phrase
who saves everything not only humans but
also the animals God's wings shelter not
just the chosen few but all people it
says it directly in God's house it says
the feast is abundant and everyone eats
their fill in God's house there is a
river of God's delights from which
everyone drinks for with god it says is
the Fountain of Life bubbling up without
end a pure spring of joy for all people
don't tell anyone though because out
there people think Christians believe in
a God who rations out blessings with
tweezers to the chosen serious view
don't tell them we worship a god that
loves all human life all human life God
loves it when two people find each other
and love each other God loves it when
babies are born God loves it when people
overcome obstacles in their lives God
loves it when enemies negotiate peace
God loves it when the cancer responds to
treatment God loves it when communities
of diverse people can get together and
celebrate we live in a world that wants
us to believe in scarcity in a long list
of impossible things there's only so
much to go around and not nearly enough
for everyone only so much love in this
world and only the most beautiful and
the perfect can have any only so much
success so only that tiny group at the
top of the pyramid could have it and
only so much God so that we have to be
sure only the righteous have access the
world wants us to live cramped little
lives always worried that we're not good
enough pretty enough smart enough and
that we must work work work to get into
the heaven of the billionaire's while
everyone else is consigned to the
gahanna of the middle class human beings
we are meant to believe live in a world
where we have to be very very careful
all the time we are always living on the
edge of disaster of poverty of
loneliness a failure of rejection of
death and whatever tiny allotment of joy
and life we've been given must be
carefully guarded lest it ever be taken
from us we need to live always looking
over our shoulders for the next disaster
to come
so don't tell anyone don't tell me when
that Christians believe in a God who
gives completely indiscriminately who
showers life down on the deserving and
the undeserving whose idea of justice is
that even the worst sinner can reach out
for forgiveness don't tell anyone
because they think they know who we are
and what we believe this doesn't mean
we're at the kingdom yet Jesus made wine
but it wasn't all parties he went out
amongst the lepers he fed the poor he
defended the woman accused of adultery
he overturned the tables of the money
chamber changers he condemned the
corruption he saw in church and state
we're clearly not there yet he's given
us a lot to do I remember going on
service trips to Nicaragua and once a
student saying to our hosts down there
I'm so moved by the people here they
have nothing and yet they're so happy
and my host responded by saying and just
imagine how happy they'd be with food
and health care and schools we have a
lot yet to do but at its best being
together here in this crazy chapel with
you worshiping this god of abundance
watching your lives unfold through
crises and self-doubt into fountains of
joy and creativity this really is like a
wedding feast
a lifelong party where everyone is
welcome and everyone is fed and so today
our feast continues we Commission new
deacons a more diverse group of students
than you could possibly imagine inviting
near strangers to lead us and represent
us because we've seen what the Holy
Spirit can do and so today we gather a
Christ tableware Candice celebrates for
the first time and where Christ feeds us
again with his limitless body at this
wedding feast of the Lamb of God but
don't tell anybody I want you to look
very serious when you leave today look
like it's been sheer misery because we
don't want anyone to know